As most of you know,
QR code stands for quick response code,
and it's a two-dimensional bar code
that holds a good deal more information
than a traditional bar code.
They originated in Japan
at the Toyota factory
to track the manufacturing of car parts.
Since then, they've taken
off in popularity,
and you'll see them everywhere
in consumer advertising.
When you scan a QR code,
you're instantly taken
to a variety of tech-based experiences:
Could be a text message,
could be an audio message,
could be a website,
could be a video.
It's like magic.
The tools to create a QR
code are essentially free,
and the tools to interact with the QR code
are increasingly easy and common to use.
So, we have this great, free, easy tool,
but what can we do with it?
Teachers have realized
there's a lot of potential
for QR codes in the classroom.
Recently, I told my class
we would be learning
some new vocabulary words,
something we do
two or three times a month.
They let out a groan
because it's kind of a boring activity.
Then, I passed out QR
codes to all my students
and told them we'd be interacting
with them with devices,
and that's how they'd find
their vocabulary list.
The attitude in the class
changed completely.
They went from groaning and moaning
to excited and enthusiastic.
I could teach the exact
same lesson using QR codes
and not using QR codes
and get a completely different attitude.
One fun activity to do with QR codes
is a scavenger hunt.
I create QR codes with tasks
assigned to them.
I hide them all around the room.
Students go with their devices
and scan them and have
to complete the task.
Recently, I hosted a technology
event at my school
and held a school-wide QR code.
Students loved it.
In grades K through 6,
they were completely engaged and excited,
literally running from code to code
because they were so excited
to see what the next task was going to be.
Students who didn't have devices with them
were begging their parents
to pull out their smart phones
so they could participate as well.
It was so refreshing to see
that level of enthusiasm
and excitement regarding learning.
A creative use for teachers for QR codes
is for positive reinforcement.
Put up a poster in your classroom
with numbered QR codes,
each one leading to a different message.
When a student needs some feedback,
tell him, 'Go scan number 5.'
'Go scan number 22.'
And the message will say,
'Great job today! I love your enthusiasm.'
'Nice work! I can see you're
working really hard.'
It's so much more exciting for a student
to get out of their seat,
scan a code,
and interact with something
for then the teacher
just to say, 'Good job!'
It's much more memorable.
Libraries have endless uses for QR codes:
scannable book reviews,
lists of reading suggestions
and book lists on the walls,
biographies.
Imagine pulling a biography
of Martin Luther King, Jr. off the shelf,
scanning a QR code,
and being instantly taken
to the "I Have a Dream" speech.
It literally makes learning come alive.
QR codes can add a nice 21st century twist
to a traditional assignment.
Each year, I have my class
create a poster for a book report,
something we've all probably done
at some point in elementary school.
It's a little bit of a boring assignment.
The kids enjoy it okay.
This time, I changed it up,
and the second step of the assignment
was to have them record their voices,
recording an audio QR code of themselves
giving a book review of the book.
They then printed the QR code,
attached it to the poster,
and gave the poster a hands-on,
interactive quality.
We put them in the hallway
and kids from all different classrooms
were walking by, scanning them,
listening to these book reviews.
It was so much more fun
than just a traditional poster.
My class recently had
the privilege of participating
in a QR code lesson
led by a teacher across the country.
If the video chat weren't exciting enough,
the fact that she incorporated
QR codes into the lesson,
my students, from their seat,
from the comfort of their classroom,
could actually scan the codes
on the computer screen,
interacting with her QR codes
from 3,000 miles away,
was incredibly exciting
and memorable for my students.
They did not stop talking
about the lesson for weeks.
You just don't get that kind of memorable,
engaging experience using a worksheet
or reading from a textbook.
QR codes have a possible use
in every grade level,
with every subject area.
Kindergarten teachers
can have their students
scan a QR code that leads
to a phonics lesson.
The music teacher can
create audio QR codes
of their students playing
instruments or singing.
PE teachera can post
real-time race results
or athletic event results,
all attached to a QR code.
The student council
or the PTO can advertise
upcoming school events
all around the school
and send home on flyers via QR code.
The possibilities with this
free and easy tool are endless.
If used properly, QR
codes have the potential
to awaken a student,
transform a lesson,
and bring down the walls
of your classroom,
creating the ultimate 21st
century learning opportunity.